Derek sivers writes about he would
always go for a cycle every day and it
would take him 40 minutes to go and he'd
be sweating at the end of it and then
one day he decided you know what I'm
just gonna enjoy the cycle ride and he
gets back he looks at the clock and it's
42 minutes damn was I really huffing and
puffing and wearing myself out for the
sake of two extra minutes that seems a
bit weird but a really excellent analogy
of how I feel pre and post therapy I'm
still achieving the same things I'm just
taking it a little bit more relaxed and
enjoying myself a little bit more and
really the amount of output that I'm
losing is minimal now I just watch a
movie before I go to bed and I do those
two tasks in the morning instead of the
night before and I just relax at the end
of the day and unwind I'm like why do I
need to be on this constant hamster
wheel I can just take a bit of a step
back and like you said it'll take me 42
minutes instead of 40 and it's not the
end of the world
[Music]